المذنب الاخضر يمر عبر الارض لاول مره منذ
العصر الجليد الاخير المذنب تم اكتشافه في
مارس من العام الماضي في مرصد بالومار
تابع لمعهد كاليفورنيا للتكنولوجيا بس سمي
بالمذنب الاخضر لانه شعو ضوء اخضر
المذنب رصده البعض بالعين المجرده دون
الاستعانه بتلسكوب ومن المفترض ان يمر
باقرب نقطه له الى الارض فوق افق القطب
الشمالي اليوم الاربعاء قبل ان يبتعد في
طريق الى خارج النظام الشمسي يوم الخميس
فجرا بتوقيت الولايات المتحده
فاحجز مقاعدك وحاول الا تفقده اثناء رحلته
عبر كوكبنا ولو حتى بمتابعه بث مباشر لحظه
بلحظه عبر الانترنت
ستكون الفرصه الاخيره التي نتمكن من
مشاهدته فيها قبل ان يزورنا ثانيه بعد
50,000 عام
على كل حال تفاصيل اكثر واوفى حول المذنب
الاخضر وما يدور حوله هند ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
وتصيبهم بالحيره بعض الثقافات تستبشروا
برؤيه النيازك والمذنبات واخرى تعتبرها
نذير شؤمن يستدعي الفزع وفي امريكا يسود
الاعتقاد بان رؤيه الشهب فرصه لطرح
الاماني علها تتحقق ولا نعرف ما خطر في
بال الانسان القديم حين برق المذنب الاخضر
في سماءه قبل 50,000 عام لكن ذلك المذنب
ذاته يعود ليزين الافق هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
كره الجليد هذه تقطع اكثر من 200,000 كلم
في الساعه وستكون الاقرب الى الارض بحسب
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا في الثاني من
فبراير محلقه 100 مره ابعد من القمر
المذنب سيت 2022 اي 3 يتوهج مخضر حين تمتص
جزيئات الكربون ثنائي الذره اشعه الشمس
وسيسلط علماء الفلك في الولايات المتحده
تلسكوب جيمس ويب لمراقبه المذنب الاخضر
حين يقترب من المريخ لفهم هذه النوعيه من
الاجرام السماويه على نحو افضل
يمكنك رؤيه هذا المذنب النادر بالعين
المجرده من مكان بعيد عن اضواء المدينه
انظر الى النجوم وستجد المذنبات لالا بين
نجم الشمال ونجمتين في نهايه كوكبه الدب
الاكبر لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن
الاقليمي
دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه المذنب الاخضر يقترب من الارض لو
نتحدث اولا عن اهميه هذا الحدث الثلاثي
اولا عشان المشاهد الكريم يعني
متابع معنا عايزين نقول المذنبات بتتكون
في النظام الشمسي الخارجي
بعضها او بعض هذه مناسبات نحو النظام
الشمسي الداخلي
تسميها حزام كده
ده موجود
يعني بعد ما دار نبتون بالضبط
كوكبته
بتدور زي ما احنا عارفين حول الشمس همم في
اقل من 200 سنه يعني همم طبعا همم موجوده
همم بشكل كبير في خلال ستاته معظم
المذنبات زي ما قلنا نحاس همم الخارجيه
البعيده اللي هي المنطقه
همم لما نزلنا بيقترب بين الارض بين
الاخضر همم نفترق الشمس اسف بيبدا التحول
الجديد هو عباره عن قريب الجريديه يعني
الى الغاز
[موسيقى]
من الغبار بتبعد بعيد جدا طب بتكون الزيت
طب ليه احنا المتاهه الاخضر ليه موجودين
ليه طلع وهو اكبر يعني ما ما اخذش لون
المطاج احمر او اي لون اخضر
احنا بنقول التوهب الاخضر همم ده مش مش
فريد لهذا المجلد اللي هو ظهر وتفسير 1000
سنه همم وده بتنشا من تفاعل بين ضوء الشمس
والكربون تلاقي الذره يعني مش شايف
الكربون كربون ثنائي الذره
نعم نعم
نعم
كربون ثنائي على شكل غازي غير مستقر
للعنصر بتاع عنصر الكربون يعني وبالتالي
تترابط في ظروف غامبول بعد الزواج ثنائي
الذره طبعا احنا بنتكلم عنه
ان هو كبير
على الكربون دي فعلا وضوء الشمس
معلومات علميه عميقه في ما يتعلق النبات
بس خلينا هيك شوي
وطبعا نعم يا دكتور
مين الناس اللي بيقدروا يرصدوا هذا المذنب
باي اماكن جغرافيا في العالم
[موسيقى]
يه وهيبقى واضح الترب من
النطق
الفضيله
جدا حتى الان مجرده
طبعا
العاديه
بعد منتصف الليل
النهارده يقدروا يميزوه همم اخوات العاديه
او لو الدنيا مظلمه يعني في مكان مصدر
ممكن بالعين مجرده
اه اوكي طب دكتور علاء يعني كل شويه بيصير
فيه ظواهر فلكيه نادره نتحدث يعني عن
ظاهره مول في هذا المذنب الاخضر اليوم
لماذا تحصل يعني هذه الظواهر وكل 50.000
عام يعني لماذا
يعني محسوبه يعني وربنا سبحانه يعني هذا
الشيء لكن في مجربات بتظهر كل 10 سنين
واقل من كده وفي نشوفها يوميه فده طبعا
من الارض من الشمس
تكلمنا على استظاء تكوين الفضاء وبقى
قبل الخريطه ده النهارده التقدم العلمي هو
اللي ازهر الاشياء دي بشكل همم
ونقدر ان احنا نرصدها همم بشكل جيد جدا
يعني دكتور علاء احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر
وما زال الفضاء يحمل الكثير من الاسرار
وحتى العلماء ما زالوا قيد الوصول الى
معلومات اكثر فاكثر واوفى في ما يدور حول
كوكب الارض شكرا جزيلا لك رئيس المكتب
الاقليم للتدريس علوم الفضاء دكتور على
المهره